president Trump's fight against the
house impeachment inquiry is turning
into a battle royal in a level 2 letter
to top congressional Democrats the
president's White House Council called
their inquiry unconstitutional and said
mr. Trump will not cooperate the White
House is daring House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi to call for a vote on impeachment
or take the president to court Pelosi
said in the statement last night quote
mr. president you are not above the law
you will be held accountable Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill Nancy what
happens now well Democrats say they're
not going to let the White House force
them into taking a vote that they say
they're not required to do and beyond
that privately some Democrats worry that
taking this vote to formalize the
impeachment inquiry would give the
minority party an opening to demand more
investigative powers of its own the
White House now says its refusal to
cooperate is rooted in the law in an 8
page memo the president's lawyer writes
that the House impeachment probe has
denied the president the right to
cross-examine witnesses to call
witnesses to have access to evidence and
many other basic rights you have a
basically investigation right now which
we're not allowed to to provide a see
evidence that they're bringing forward
we're not allowed to cross-examine
Democrats say the memo simply invents
excuses just don't walk this is really
unprecedented Congress has a
responsibility to conduct oversight it's
a particularly serious responsibility in
the context of an impeachment inquiry
Democrats are gathering evidence around
the president's now infamous July phone
call with the Ukrainian president an
early memo from the whistleblower cited
a White House official who was on the
call and described it as crazy and
frightening the American people have the
right to know if the president is acting
in their interests the house issued
another subpoena Tuesday after the
administration blocked Gordon Sunland a
key witness from sitting for a
deposition at the last minute the
president said he couldn't allow Sunland
to go before a totally compromised
kangra
court this entire thing is a political
charade a group of Republicans defended
mr. Trump even as they urged the White
House to loop them in next time and I
said the same thing where we wish he
would have been able to testify to but
we fully understand why the
administration made the decision they
did Democrats argue that if they were to
take this formal vote that the White
House wants the president would simply
come up with some other reason to block
them from getting access to documents
and witnesses yesterday on a
teleconference with reporters a senior
administration official refused to
answer questions about the conditions
under which the White House would
cooperate yeah all right Nancy thank you